garth brooks is he going to do a
collaboration with chris pratt
chris is the ultimate fanboy he jumped
on stage with garth at last year's
iheart radio awards
then last month he dropped this cryptic
news
i'm working on something i'm going to
work on i'm doing something garth brooks
wow yeah it's kind of top secret but i i
can say that much i guess
chris pratt kind of let it slip out that
he might be working on something with
you
what are you two what are you two doing
together i love chris and i think chris
is trying to figure out how to get me on
this project but here's the problem
uh you know i've spent my entire life
fighting to own my stuff and when you
get into movies and music
the the movie place owns it so i told
chris man i love you but i might have to
step out of this thing
but i think he keeps bringing it up
hoping that i think he's going to change
my mind
he's such a sweet guy and an
unbelievable talent
i enjoy i enjoy his company it's always
a joy it's funny though my wife seems to
enjoy it more i don't know why
i spoke with garth today who announced
he's pulling himself out of the running
for cma's entertainer of the year award
he also revealed that his daughter ali
colleen has been battling coronavirus
she said she had a sore throat was the
most thing that she had but
truth is as a parent nobody knows what
cove is going to do in the future
so you you just watch over them hold
them you pray a lot
and hopefully uh she'll come out of this
thing with just
[Music]
that